With their independently rotating eyes, color change abilities,...
...their pincer-like feet, their long tongue that they project out of their mouth,...
...and their slow, deliberate movements.
Chameleons are animals that most people would regard as highly charismatic.
One of the old theories as to why chameleons change color...
...was that they were changing color to match their background.
But what we now know is that it's actually a communication strategy.
Male-male combat will elicit some of the most impressive colorations from males.
From females, on the other hand, if a female's gravid...
...or she has eggs and is not interested in breeding,...
...if a male starts to try and court her,...
...she will display some very intense, vibrant colorations...
...to let the male know that she's not interested.
Chameleons have fascinated scientists and naturalists for centuries.
It's something that we're still learning a lot about.